>> Gutfeld: IF YOU MEMORIZED PI
TO 16 PLACES, CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE A GREAT BIG RACIST.
GREAT RHYME IT'S THE LEFT'S NEW
RELIGION.
SOLVING FOR X LEAVES THEM ASKING
WHY.
THROUGH THE WOKESTER'S THEME,
YOU SEE A WHITE PATRIARCHAL PAST
ESPECIALLY WITH THE HES ARABIC
NUMERALS.
WANT TO FOCUS ON COLONIALISM AND
PRIVILEGE, BUT NOT THE PRIVILEGE
THAT LETS YOU WASTE $78,000 A
YEAR IN TUITION.
A GROUP OF PROFESSION SORES AND
STUDENTS SUGGEST CALCULUS COULD
SITUATE RACE, WHITE SUPREMACY,
COLONIALISM AND POWER AND
PRIVILEGE THROUGHOUT THE COURSE.
I HAVEN'T DISCOVERED THIS MUCH
POPPY COB SINCE I STUMBLED ON
THAT NUDE BEACH FOR SENIORS.
BUT, IF THE CHANGE IS ADOPTED,
THE GLASSES WOULD BE MANDATORY.
ONE OF THE COURSES IS CALLED
MATHEMATICS FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
I WONDER WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE?
>> HELLO, I'M THE PROFESSOR OF
NUMBERS.
TAKE YOUR SEAT BASED ON RACE,
GENDER IDENTITY AND LEVEL OF
BODY POSITIVITY.
THE WAIT LIST FOR THIS CLASS IS
A MILE LONG.
FRANKLY, YOU'RE LUCKY TO FIND AN
OPEN CHAIR.
NOW, BYING THAT REAM, ISAAC
NEWTON, ALBERT EINSTEIN, ALL
MATHEMATICIANS, BIGOTS.
DO YOU KNOW THE APPLE THAT HIT
NEWTON ON THE HEAD WAS HIT BY A
MIGRANT WORKER.
IF YOU DON'T THINK MATH WILL
IMPACT YOUR LIFE, JUST WAIT
UNTIL YOUR WIFE TAKES HALF OF
YOUR [ BLEEP ]
SORRY, MR. CROISSANT, DOCTOR?
DOCTOR, ISN'T MATH KIND OF THE
UNIVERSAL CONSTANT THAT UNITES
EVERYBODY REGARDLESS OF
GEOGRAPHICAL AND POLITICAL
AFFILIATION?
>> NO, I THINK I HAVE A PROBLEM
FOR YOU THAT YOU'RE REALLY GOING
TO LOVE.
2 PLUS 2 EQUALS GET THE
[ BLEEP ]
OUT OF MY CLASS YOU WHITE HOME
FOLK.
-- HOMOPHOBE.
>> I HAVE ON MY NOTEBOOK.
>> THAT'S ENOUGH FOR TODAY.
NEXT WEEK, WHY THE NAZIS
INVENTED CALCULUS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Gutfeld: YOU'RE A RACIST.
IS MATHEMATICS LIKE AN EMBLEM OF
WHITE SUPREMACY?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
NO.
THIS IS THE FIRST I'M HEARING OF
IT.
IF THE -- I THINK THE WOKE THING
IS GETTING A LITTLE BIT OUT OF
CONTROL.
WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE, I WASN'T
EVEN WOKE FOR MOST OF MY EARLY
CLASSES.
AND I DON'T KNOW -- HOW IS THIS
GOING TO END?
WHEN I DID TAKE CALCULUS, WE ALL
WERE TAKING CALCULUS AND I WAS
THINKING, GOSH I WISH IT'S MORE
COMPLICATED WITH MORE VARIABLES.
THE TRAIN IS GOING 50 MILES PER
HOUR.
THE TRAIN IS GOING NORTH.
IT'S DRIVEN BY A CIS WHITE MALE.
WHY DON'T YOU CHECK THE TRAIN
SCHEDULE?
>> WHEN YOU SAY MATH IS RACIST,
IT'S LIKE SAYING A SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE IS RACIST BECAUSE YOU
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
BUT MATH IS A UNIVERSAL
LANGUAGE.
ANYBODY CAN DO IT.
>> RIGHT.
BUT -- I CAN DO SOME MATH.
BUT I DON'T NEED IT BECAUSE OF
MY CHARM AND BRILLIANCE IN OTHER
AREAS.
>> AND I PHONE CALCULATOR.
>> YEAH, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BUT THIS IS THE CONCLUSION OR
PROBABLY NOT -- PROBABLY WILL
GET WORSE, OF SOMETHING WHERE IF
YOU DISAGREE, YOU'RE A RACIST IS
BUILT INTO IT.
SO SOMEONE COULD BE IN THAT
MEETING LIKE, OH, I THINK MATH
CLASS SHOULD BE ABOUT MATH?
LIKE YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT BUT YOU CAN'T IN THIS
SITUATION.
PEOPLE WILL SAY, OH, THAT'S YOUR
PRIVILEGE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE
WHITE OR NOT.
YOU CAN BE A WHITE SUPREMACIST
EVEN IF YOU'RE NOT A WHITE
PERSON.
>> Gutfeld: THAT'S TRUE, THAT'S
TRUE.
SHELLENBERGER, WHO WE HAD ON
LAST NIGHT, HE CALLED IT SECOND
DEGREE RACISM WHERE YOU DECIDE A
GROUP CAN'T HANDLE SOMETHING
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN HANDLE.
SO BY LOOKING OUT FOR THEM,
YOU'RE THE BIGOT, THAT MAKE
SENSE?
>> IT DOES.
I WANT TO USE MY OXFORD
EDUCATION FOR ONCE.
BUT THESE PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
IS THEY'RE WRONG IN THEIR OWN
TERMS.
OUR NUMBER SYSTEM, THE ARABIC
NUMERAL SYSTEM WAS INVENTED BY
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IT WAS INVENTED BY THEM.
IT WAS THEIR GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
BUT YET THEY HAVE NO MEMORY FOR
IT.
HALF OF THESE THINGS THAT WE SAY
ARE RACIST OR BLAMED ON WHITE
PEOPLE WERE STOLEN BY WHITE
PEOPLE FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
SO HERE'S TO ARABIC NUMERALS AND
THE NUMBER ZERO WHICH THEY
INVENTED.
>> YEAH, MY FAVORITE NUMBER.
AND WHAT -- WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO
SAY?
>> WELL, THIS ENTIRE THING IS AN
ILLUSTRATION OF WHAT WE ARE
GOING THROUGH SOCIALLY IN THIS
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
BASE COLLEGE HAS 2,000 STUDENTS.
YOU PAY $80,000 TO GO THERE.
THIS WORKING GROUP CONSISTED OF
FIVE PROFESSORS, FIVE STUDENTS,
THREE OF WHOM WERE FRESHMEN,
THEY'RE 17.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
TO THE POINT EARLIER WHERE
IGNORANT PEOPLE WERE IN SCHOOL
BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING
EDUCATED.
STUDENTS ARE RIDICULOUS.
PEOPLE ARE LISTENING TO THEM.
THAT'S A MICROCOSM.
ONE LOUD PERSON ON TWITTER
SHOUTS A RIDICULOUS WOKE
THING -- THIS PERSON IS
CANCELLED, THIS PERSON IS
RACIST.
THIS IS WHAT IT SHOULD BE.
OH, YES, ABSOLUTELY.
THE EMPEROR'S NEW CLOTHES.
THE EMPEROR'S NO CLOTHES.
THEY EAR SCARED OF GETTING
CANCELLED TOO.
>> THEY'RE SCARED OF LOUD
17-YEAR-OLDS.
>> SIMILAR, I WENT TO OXFORD
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I LIKE MATH THAT MAKES SENSE.
I DON'T JUST GET RID OF
CALCULUS.
I WANT MATH THAT CAN BE USEFUL
IN REGULAR LIFE.
MATH, SAY THERE'S 13 OF US.
AND WE HAVE A 12 PACK OF BEER.
YOU HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT,
RIGHT?
12 OF YOU NEED TO LEAVE